marketing for the now the marketing for
the now
marketing for the now marketing for the
now 10 minutes
12 remarkable guests for two hours
answering a singular important question
[Music]
are you ready gary what do you think
gary gary gary yes andrea
guess what what's that it's episode
number 25.
i can't believe it unbelievable and
we're actually gonna talk
about one question how do you stay close
to culture
but we're only going to do it for an
hour with six guests
and we've got a pretty hot one to kick
things off so let's not waste any time
hashtag marketing for the now let's go
first up we welcome
liam payne recording artist and former
member
of one direction how are we doing guys
good to see you thank you for having me
liam how are you my friend i am really
good i was just saying to everyone i
feel like over here in the uk we are
terrible at dealing with the heat and
it's very hot over here at the moment
but i'm doing great
so liam you know i think um obviously
there are very few people that have
touched
the actual sun of pop culture
literally in the history of the last 100
years
given just the sheer popularity globally
of the band so at a very young age you
were at the presbyters
of it um you know you and i become
friendly this year because of
your incredible nft project and once
again
you find yourself very close to culture
from a creative lens
being a fast mover and learner and
student
and creator in that space what do you
think it is
about your your life's journey your
personality trait the serendipity like
you know why has that happened and then
more importantly
outside of the things you're actively
doing how are you staying on
top of what's cool because really that's
what the slang tune culture
means right here from uh just genuinely
knowing whether it's
as simple as which restaurants to go to
in london or uh or new york or la
who the popular artists are which social
media people matter what platforms
matter what clothes matter like
how how are you how do you go about that
um i mean i think i've been fairly lucky
as time's gone on to learn about this
as my career has kind of progressed and
i don't think i really understood it
very
much at a young age but when i look back
on things
i mean i think everything these days is
really technology
led and when i got the question for for
for this i was really thinking deeply
into the idea behind ai and algorithms
right i mean i feel like tick-tock i i
had a chance to talk to the cmo of
tick-tock and
there was a shortage of feta cheese at
one point in the world from how much
tick-tock was pushing feta cheese which
seems crazy to me
but i think there's there's a real thing
for me on on staying on top of things at
the moment the way i
i program these algorithms and ais for
myself i mean it's very easy
you know to get lost in cuddly cat
videos and funny stuff on tick tock but
i think if you really
go about your searches to find the
things that you're very interested in
um it can really take you on a journey
to experience it and finding these these
new things and what's hot right now
uh more than you realize who in your
life
has been great at this like a buddy like
a mate a manager
a former relationship like who when i
say to you like who really is in the
know
i mean you've met steve multiple times
i'd say he has always been the one for
me and i think
there is a there is a strong thing i
mean my friend ed edwards
who who is the editor for vogue is the
same
keeping around young people who really
sponge this
up um i think it is a really really
strong move um you know i i think it was
through twitter
places like twitter instagram it's the
young who are really leading the
forefront on these things what's what's
cool and what's now
um and for us you know working through
our businesses i mean
the main one for me and i already spoke
to you this about this before i came on
it's been mental health at the moment
has been pushed so far to the forefront
and i think in terms of investment and
in terms of
of lifestyle and the way we think about
ourselves mental health has really
really become a big one for me what
about um
what about the concept of which
categories do you feel like you have an
incredible pulse of
what's happening in its culture and
which categories if i said to you over
the next 10 years
you'll get better at knowing fine dining
or or sneaker culture like
where do you feel at this moment in your
career where do you feel
very solid and where are some categories
that you wish you could get better and
proven
yes um i mean uh
i think cryptocurrency is a really big
one for me that i want to get more in
the know about um
i'm only just starting to learn from a
lot of friends and different things
about how this is i've been very
unfortunate
the times i've ever invested in
cryptocurrency it's not at the bottom of
the dip
so i'm always catching back up to what i
have i mean i was in 2017
um when when i invested and i only
recently got to know someone who was
responsible for the dip
after i invested he's now a friend of
mine which is terrible
um so i think that's definitely one for
me um and i think that there's a really
tricky water on this one in terms of
tick tock and people giving financial
advice you know i think that
we've given the world and the way covert
is right now you know we're all really
searching for
things like that uh at home and ways we
can make money and look after ourselves
and be
you know self-sustainable in that way so
i think it's a tricky one with tick-tock
on that
i mean it for me myself i've been very
blessed
with the the friends and people i've met
along the way
in terms of fashion um which has always
been a really uh
good and fun one for me i mean some
people online will probably disagree
with this but
yeah that's the world isn't it how it
works who
who has stood out for you that's really
shaped your fashion
um you know sense or knowledge
um i mean my friend my friend uh edwards
uh who has been is the editor of vogue
he's the editor of
uh most of europe's folks i think now as
well um
and i mean his career is only going up
and up there was a real moment for me
when
you know when you meet someone you don't
really know very much about them i
didn't know a lot about it because i met
him through
through steve actually and we we stood
in an art gallery looking at all of the
covers of
vogue that he's done so far in a lineup
and it was like wow this guy is actually
right on the pulse of this he knows
exactly what he's doing meaning meaning
it was one of those classic things where
like
this person's on the cover of august and
then six months later
they're really crushing and have crossed
the chasm oh yeah and i mean
he just picks the best people he picks
the best the best fashion the best
layout
and also the things that the magazine
talks about as well so i mean i really
look to him
for a lot of advice and you know i hope
he feels the same about me in some way
before we get out of here because these
go quick we got two minutes what
what what kind of content do you feel
is what really gets you to understand
are you a reader
is it podcasts is it social media
content
is it sitting down and having a proper
pub you know beer
or or coffee uh you know what
when you're absorbing your information
what do you think from like a learner
standpoint because i think one of the
reasons people struggle with culture
is they don't understand how they learn
yeah they try to read it and reading is
it like
if i just read long form
i would be nowhere because it doesn't
absorb but quick
you know somebody made a comment that my
eyes are on the comments while i'm
interviewing it's true i'm taking in
feedback that way
audio you know if i have a conversation
i grasp it
but yeah are you i think for me i i'm
the same i can't i'd love
to be a reader i'd love to be able to
sit and read and it's definitely a skill
that i want to hone in on
i mean given our attention spans these
days i think i'm definitely one of those
people who need to take in short sharp
bursts but i'd say
for me more in the learning and the more
i invest in the more people
i meet in particular with this this
latest shareholder i've done in entire
life sciences i've had to learn about
biotech and biotech is not
in any means of pop stars realm of i
have no right being in this space but
it's amazing to learn about the
severeness of the mental health
uh crisis that we have right now in the
world there's one billion people and
there's no silver bullet for any of this
so
learning these medications and learning
how we're going to apply them
with you know supervision it's not the
same as a as a cannabis thing you can go
and buy over the counter these things
are sold in terms of supervised
uh thing that you go through to really
you know get the best out of them in
that way and that was hard for me to
learn but
my friend said to me is that you never
seem to argue a point when we discuss
these things i was like i have no
education that's how i'm going
i have to take it in as a as a huge
yapper people are stunned when i'm quiet
for 40 minutes out of dinner i'm like
we're talking about
health insurance i don't know anything
exactly i have to i can only take in i'm
uneducated and i do not want to make a
point right now so that's
that's my thing is it's all about who
you surround yourself with and also
with your instincts going with your
instincts is a big one we need to run
liam thank you so much have a wonderful
day cheers mate
thank you guys andrew before you
introduce everybody else i just put a
link into the v friends discord
if you just came over from that please
leave a comment uh
uh if you are from the v friends discord
and share the url to this score let's
get some more friends in there go ahead
andre
next up we're we're lucky to welcome
morgan flatley
she's the chief marketing and digital
customer experience officer at
mcdonald's
in her four years there morgan has built
the capabilities to put
digital data and insights at the heart
of all things marketing at mcdonald's
accelerating the power of social media
and breakthrough creative
welcome morgan thank you hey gary it's
great to be here with you finally it's
good to see you
it's great to see you yes finally for
everybody wondering what morgan's
referencing
we've been chasing her on this show
she's one of the great marketers
in uh in our world and uh every subject
we cover
is something i feel that she can bring
tons of value to
uh but this one's especially exciting
for me because i think that you've been
at the forefront
as a leader i really feel my personal
opinion one man's point of view
i think the brand at mcdonald's it feels
more culturally relevant today than it
has in a long time
and i'm sure there's other key
executives that allow that to happen but
this is your remit so i give
plenty of credit on this and so i guess
very quickly before we even you know
maybe we break this down
i think this would be fun for people to
hear how do you morgan the human
the human stay close to culture and then
how do you morgan
this very senior executive at the
forefront of one of the biggest brands
in the world
stay close to culture and
are there any differences and i'd love
for you to pontificate a little bit on
that
yeah so first i was holding out until
your 25th
um number back at your 50th and
hopefully
um so you know it's funny it's hard for
me to separate out the two first i'll
say
and more as morgan the executive
i find this really hard to do and
because of just all the demands you know
on my time
on all of our times and like the need to
operate at
so many different levels across the
organization that it's really hard to
find
time and space to stay connected to
culture and and
even just listening to you and liam like
it was such a good
trigger that i've got to do a better job
the
the the best way i do this is
is i actually surround myself with
people who are really really good at it
and you know i and it's funny liam
touched on this
like i find it's often it's often
younger people who like are just
absorbing
from so many different places and they
probably have
you know a little bit more of the
attention span to be able to do that
than i do
um it's their every day morgan i just
wanna i'm sorry to jump in literally
help a lot of people understand what
you're saying you have so many things
eating up that 9 10 11 12 13 hour day
yeah big girl stuff right big big big
decisions forward planning like
heavy meetings when you've got somebody
who's 26
by nature they aren't gonna have as
big of a load and they're up late like
they're just at a different part of
their life
and it's their every day right the music
the fashion
the tick tock stream that's just part of
their everyday it's not work
it's their oxygen just like for you
you're out back to your point of
it's difficult and i and it's been the
biggest stunner to me
coming into corporate america i'm like
wow
cmos are in a tough spot it's crazy one
of the things that makes me
unique i think is i fight for a stunning
amount of hours per day
in the dirt and i think that's what
helped me
now i pay a consequence for that because
my big boy stuff
is always a little slower because two
hours went to be in a discord or watch
tick tock
or be in the trenches in a studio in
atlanta
so i it's a real tough game it's true
and i think it's like great advice for
cmos for executives to like protect that
time when you can get in the dirt like i
love that phrase
and for me it's like sitting around with
the team
and it's often my junior team
forgive me that's my husband trying to
facetime me
up the good stuff right talk about being
in the dirt man
um so i mean i
love sitting around with with like the
more junior people in the organization
or our creative teams like i get a
ton of inspiration from our creative
teams
and using that to like inspire me and
then i'll go
follow some of what they've talked about
so i think it's it's about like being
curious
and really really taking the time to
like listen and debate it that's how i
learn
is like through other people and that
discussion and that discord
that like helps me start to at least
point myself in the right directions
to get kind of connected to culture how
help all the smbs mid-level companies
entrepreneurs and youngsters understand
the following friction that i'm dying to
hear your answer to this is very selfish
but it's gonna bring a ton of value
how hard is it for you when you know
something's cool
but it's just edgy enough that you're
scared to do it for something
as big and corporate
yeah and and like for the masses as
mcdonald's like
where does an executive like yourself
have to draw the line
where you're like how hard is that
decision on the thing you green light or
you
kill because anything that cool by
nature
has teeth in it totally that corporate
right and you've done some great
collaboration
right with valve and others you know
like like there's that decision making
curve
how much of that at the when you get to
the highest levels of marketing and the
biggest companies in the world
how much of that is like you're like the
things that you really stress through
when you're brushing your teeth and god
darn it
should we go because you know it's hot
but is it too hot where you might get
burned
and then the problem is and you know
this the problem is then so many
corporations go with things that are not
hot and nobody gives a [ __ ]
exactly and like people can sniff that
out in a second i mean i
my last year here and i was just in a
meeting which i'll
when in a week or two i'll play back to
you where
the conversations that i needed to have
with our executive team like i can't
believe some of the things i've had to
talk through
um i just so so a few things
i think my job is to push the risk and
if and that's why and i loved where you
started mcdonald's is starting to feel
culturally relevant again
because we're pushing the risk yeah and
what i
tend to do and i've talked about this
before i have a couple people who are
like
on the pulse of culture and i talked to
them
i talked to them offline i can i
literally called one of them two days
ago who shall remain nameless
and i was like help me think through how
much risk we're taking on help me think
through what's the good what's the bad
what's the ugly
and and then i feel like we just have to
go for it
i mean i need to watch the brain if the
brand is going to get
permanently damaged that's my job to
make sure we don't do permanent damage
to the brand
i apologize jump in because i think you
can answer this and i
i live in a world where if you look at
the last five
15 12 10 years there have been some
gnarly things that have happened
right where brands have sponsored some
celebrities that have crashed and burned
massively yeah there have been i mean
over the last six years the country in
general is more politicized and there's
tension right
yeah what i've been fascinated by is big
company executives think a lot about
permanent damage
and i'm watching behavior and i'm
looking at numbers
and i think what's fascinating is it's
almost impossible for permanent damage
because of the way the consumer's
working these days
you know it's true keep going i think
brands are so much more resilient
than we and i think rumors are resilient
and when you sit around a board room you
forget that like
literally you forget it and i said
yesterday
there might be like a negative article
but it'll all be gone the next day
like the way people are experiencing
culture and brands like they move on
quickly and i think it takes
really really really significant
missteps
for it to be permanently damaging i i
just think brands are resilient
and consumers are also resilient i think
that's an incredible way to wrap up it
goes so fast i think for the big
cmos in here understanding how resilient
brands are
may actually allow you to win in culture
it's so true and you have to take those
risks
you have to have a great rest of your
summer yeah bye gary
love that next up we've got bracken
daryl
president and ceo of logitech taking on
the role
nine years ago and since then logitech
has reinvented itself
into an award-winning design company an
industry force
in pursuing a more sustainable and equal
world and a top performer in the stock
market
welcome brecken hey thank you thanks for
having me hey gary
how you doing brother i'm doing well
brother how are you i'm great
before i go anywhere one of my favorite
ceos truly and i say that i want to do
it publicly
mainly because of curiosity and humility
and i'm
and and that's the truth back and i i
recently a week ago somebody asked me
about you
uh because they so were connected on
linkedin i'm like oh i actually really
know him because
you know obviously sometimes you're
connected with people you have no idea
who they are
i'm like and and i it just flowed i'm
like you know
it's rare to see real leaders who've had
real success consistently for a decade
have that level of curiosity and
humility and i guess
leading the witness because i'm excited
to have you here
a do you humbly do you agree with
that you have a piece of that do you
think that's trickle to the org and most
of all
has that been the reason that you've
been pretty successful
in getting close to culture whether it's
esports or other things sustainability
like
thoughts on my rant yeah yeah well i
guess you know
it will focus on the curiosity part you
know i think
um yeah i thought about what is
curiosity you know curiosity is not just
wondering about things it's actually
wondering about things and then going to
seek and find out about them
and i think if you are curious you're
going to naturally be closer to the
things that are happening today
and uh and then if you're curious and
you're
and you're active about it so you're you
know then then you're probably gonna end
up
talking to a lot wider range of people
and i would say uh
if i'm if i'm close to culture at all
and i'm not sure that i belong on this
show but
if i am close to culture in places that
matter it's because of the people around
me
and because i am super curious
do you think you're close to culture do
you think the organization is
i think you know what i think i'm lucky
and this isn't humility
gary i think i'm lucky i'm i'm i've got
certain values
that i really believe in you know and
they ca and i keep adding to them over
time you know they don't really change
they just get more
more dramatic and then i add other ones
and i think
things like uh you know sustainability
uh de and i uh design there are things i
believe in so much and if you kind of
took those and you
made a venn diagram out of two of them
or three of them you know you'd end up
on on some edge of culture that's super
exciting you know and
so i think if i'm close to culture it's
probably more about kind of just
basically who i am
and less about me kind of staying close
to it
is that the luck of good parenting
well like you know i feel very similar
and when i use the term lucky i'm like
circumstance of childhood greatest
mother of all time
built up self-esteem while held me
accountable so a no [ __ ] self-esteem
woman
i'm the greatest i do something [ __ ]
up you know that kind of you know so i
i was in the middle and then immigrant
with nothing so i
i wasn't entitled how to fight for
everything i [ __ ] had do you think
you being you just answering this
question when you say lucky and i
understand that do you think that's the
luck of good parenting and
childhood circumstance yeah for sure i
mean we're all we're all lucky if we
have a mom who just uh you know adores
us
and me and my siblings did i mean we
just had an incredible mom and
and she left us feeling comfortable that
no matter what we did even if
we screwed something up it's okay
because we can recover and be great
you know do great things and i think
that's part of this act of curiosity you
know
i was listening to your last uh
discussion i thought it was really
fascinating this idea of risk you know
yeah i think the biggest risk is not
being aggressive
and and you know not playing offense all
the time you know there's
obviously you've got to make sure you're
not walking on the ledge with no
nowhere to land with the ground but but
i i mean really it's it's there's no
such thing about risk the way people
think about it most of the time most
people think about risk too much and not
enough about
playing offense i totally agree do you
think that's the nate you know
me and morgan could be correct you and i
could be correct you think that's just
just a game of people
realizing that they work in a
corporation and that the corporation and
the logo
will cut bait with the executive if the
pr storm happens
and then people have families i mean you
got you guys have family you know
for me entrepreneurship's fun i have no
board i'm not publicly held
like nobody's firing me back nobody's
firing me
so i'm crazy risk offense
because when i lose i look in the mirror
back there in the well there's a hotel
room but i would look back in the mirror
and be like you're an idiot
and then i move on with my day i have a
lot of empathy for my corporate friends
they might be right with the risk one
bad luck thing that happens
and they're fired and then that's not
fun and so i think
a lot of the reasons big companies
aren't risk adverse is because the
human is protecting their family yeah i
agree with that and i think you know the
i think part of this is i loved her
description of the cmos one of the cmo's
jobs is to push the
push the risk push things that seem
risky to other people
and i think that's the ceo's job as well
i mean it's great
the most because because i've got a
board whose job is to control the risk
they're going to govern the risk so i
have to be the one that says
i would argue i'm sorry to jump in but i
got to say it i would argue watching
from afar
this is why i think you're the fact that
you know that which i think is
incredibly rare in ceo love
i think ceos think they are and i think
it's to your point it's the board
and i genuinely believe that the
re-contemporary
nature the the what logitech has done
in being so much more contemporary today
than it was when you got there and
especially over the last four to five
years because i'm sure you had to clean
up
stuff or i'm making assumptions here but
has to do with the fact that you
actually know that you're
you're on offense and i believe eight
out of ten
fortune 500 ceos and i know a lot of
them they think they're defense
yeah well you know what it's it's hard
for me to speak to anybody but my
situation but
i feel very lucky you know and if you
think we've been pushing it so far
wait till you see what's coming you know
we're we're always trying to
accelerate into the future you know and
i think that's the way
yeah i it's just mo sort of my
philosophy of life is mean you just got
to keep
if you're not going if you're not if
you're not going forward you're going
backwards if you're not
you know it's all about playing offense
all the time so
i'm i'm i think it builds on itself too
and you know if you can get through
those early days as you're in
your new role where you take a little
risk and you push a little hard and
nothing
too bad happens who in your world
gives you information of what's cool to
the target audience or just in the world
family friends executives something left
field outside
who when i ask you that question what
names or energies come to mind
well you know i'll just list a few
people corinne bate uh
created blue level training she's in the
de ni space
i've learned so much from her uh
prakasha erin kundra who's my head of
operations
he's the he's the absolute expert on
environmental sustainability as well as
robert o'mahani
um in design my head of design alistair
curtis and then the royal college of art
you know
there i've got i'm surrounded by people
and meredith rojas
a relatively new person for our company
she's been there about a year she's in
the middle she wrote a book called
selfie made
she's in the middle of 14 15 year old
influencers on tick tock you know she
knows that place they love her i mean
she looks 14 or 50.
it's it's amazing you know and so these
people are all around me you know and
i'm and i feel so
lucky you know it's like i'm getting
like the waves are crashing on me i'm
not having to go find the surf you know
this is this is i'm finding out what
culture is from the people around me
what um what what areas of culture
are most interesting to you the human
like you the human
if you were like to stop working and
take a one-year sabbatical
is it in gaming sports food
traveling what where would you
personally want to know
the true cutting edge of what's truly
happening the cool cool cool
you know i a couple of areas that just
pop into mine but i'm interested in so
many areas right
one is just the creator culture you know
the
which you know by the way that's
incredibly broad but the creator culture
right now is so exciting to me you know
i'm
i'm on the east coast right now i'm in
new york but you know atlanta is like is
like
i mean it's the coolest 100 you know i
thought the creative culture is really
cool i think the trans culture
is super cool i've got that that's a
company called
founded by chloe freeman and you know
she's creating a place to go for trans
people you know who
who you know if i want products
merchandise you know i think those
those those are just two areas i mean
there's so many that i'm interested in
but i think those are too exciting
and then the overall spade space of uh
the rise of activism activism activism
activism activism on on things that
matter and activism on things that
matter to you
even if they they're relative minded
other people i think
this world of individuality you know no
we're no longer
you know culture let's talk about
company culture gary that
unfortunately we're out of time but
company calls you fascinating i'm i'm
starting to believe that company culture
is way overrated and individuality is
way underrated in companies
and this is the future of a company i
think i think i think company company
culture
is predicated on empathy and giving
people space
not conforming to what i mean i could
100
figure 100 i totally agree on that gary
i mean it's been the single biggest
reason
vayner's exploding i can tell you that
right now it's room to breathe
not conform into what i want my friends
make fun of me all the time they come to
vayner
at five o'clock there's nobody there
they're like hey mr hustle hard-working
guy
where's all your people i'm like i don't
want my people to follow what i do
i want them to follow what they do
exactly
you i mean uh okay last i'll i'll get
the last one
i really think this the the future of
organizations is they have a purpose
they have a few values they really
believe in and they're they're a place
there are club people join
who share that purpose and share those
values
there is no such thing as a culture the
way we've traditionally designed it it
just doesn't make sense
i love it i'll talk to you soon brother
thanks take care
so gary i'm personally super fired up
about our next
guest he is the president of thredup
anthony moreno
and thread up i have become so addicted
i literally got this package this
morning my husband was like what is this
why do we get so many of these
and they've been around since 2009
it's a consignment an online consignment
it is
so fabulous i'm going to get off because
i want to hear you guys talk about it
but i am an addict
for a very good reason he's awesome hey
thanks
hey how are you i'm well but not as well
as you i mean
you can't start it better than that
right that was faith i loved especially
how she threw the thing off the camera
that was a very vaudevillian of her i
loved it i think you need to chop that
up and that needs to be a commercial for
you guys anthony royalty's coming your
way coming your way fast actually
actually because i think um
you know for one minute just give us the
spiel because i do think some people
are unaware of you know obviously it's
still a young company just give us
one minute on what the company is so
people can check it out and i want to
get into culture
yeah sure so um so thread up sells
second-hand clothing on the internet
so if you go to thredup.com or download
the app you can
uh find amazing brands from gap to gucci
for up to 90
off retail and it's amazing for your
wallet
it's amazing for your closet it's
amazing for the planet because we're
we've up cycled over 100 million items
since the company was founded
and it's all you doing it right it's not
like it's not like a
where i can list something that's
sitting around in my like i can't take
this and one day list it it's not a
marketplace it's it's
you right well those are those are
fantastic
so the way it works is we make it super
super easy
for um for you to send your clothes to
us you come to our website you order
what we call the thread up clean out bag
which is
a big green polka dot hamper sized bag
and
um or you can print out just a shipping
label we you can
put all your clothing uh women's kids
women's clothing kids clothing
accessories in the bag
we pick it up for free we then process
it photograph it price it and sell it
and send you money
uh when when all that's done so it's
super easy for the seller to get rid of
things they're no longer wearing and it
turns out
america has a lot of stuff uh in its
closets that it's not
that it's not wearing i love it and
what's the split between the person that
sends it in and the company
it depends so if you send us uh a
you know a 10 t-shirt you know
um we'll pay you a lot less for it than
if you sell us a
very expensive handbag so but you know
we're
um but we're you know but we're making
the markets in those things meaning i
get it
but there's there's lots of places you
can go frankly to get rid of a beautiful
louis vuitton handbag so for that we pay
you a lot
but i understand supply and demand
applying demand gary you invented it so
you know better than anybody i
definitely didn't invent it but i gotta
tell you
like it's probably the only thing i
actually know and here i am
25 years later in my career doing quite
well off a very
very very simplistic uh
concept that i think is pure religion
anyway we're having too much fun
yeah because you're able to sit at the
heights of this company
you probably have a tremendous
understanding of what's happening in
culture because i think the people that
shop your your site are actually quite
progressive and a little bit cooler in a
lot of ways in my opinion that runs the
gamut i watch it from afar
closely but you probably have a good
sense of what's brewing
and so a you know do you take advantage
of that and then more importantly
in running the company how do you get
information how do you stay close
to having your ear to the ground yeah so
uh many of the conceptions people have
about who
buys second hand clothing are just wrong
that's been one of the greatest
learnings for me i've been at the
company for almost eight years
uh millionaires buy secondhand clothing
and people living on a budget a tight
budget
buy secondhand clothing i actually i
actually think i've always thought the
edges
were more like i think what you're doing
is making the middle come into the game
a lot more
the edges always really played that's
exactly right so
there were always those core hardcore
thrifters
who didn't talk about the fact that they
could find amazing brands
they would go and they would rifle
through racks they would go to obscure
online sites they would find
groups on social networks and buy things
and what we did
was take all this incredible product
from across america we have millions and
millions of items listed on thredup
today across 35 000 women's and kids
brands
and we made it just as easy for you to
shop those items as if you were buying
new clothing you can search it
you can filter it you can set up an
email where when a j
crew dress comes in in size three that's
red that's in the pattern you want comes
in we'll send you a text
so we made that that those folks who are
on the
you know the secret that was out about
thrift for those people on the fringes
we made it so that everybody else can
get in on it and it's amazing
last year alone 33 million people in
america purchased secondhand clothing
for the first time um so it was it was
interesting while everyone was locked at
home
and focused on their health focused on
their homes focused on saving money
they started to look for alternative
ways to shop and do things and
and i think resale in general was a big
beneficiary of that
from uh from a trying to get a sense of
where the customer is going from a
marketing standpoint
from you just being an executive that
wants to keep staying sharp and
be good at understanding consumer how do
you think about culture how do you think
about cool
how do you think about ultimately what
we're saying is consumer
demand or the emerging thing that's
going to trigger consumer demand
how important has this been to you has
it gained
you know as a youngster did it was that
something you cared about or did that
grow
because you were more operational like
when we talk about this and you just
filter through your cycle you know
especially
setting eight years in this company like
it's such a big factor brand and culture
so underrated by operational math
financiers
how do you think about that and that
what was your personal journey did you
grow up
kind of through that path or did you
have to learn it and respect it more
along the way
yeah so about everything i learned about
being a student of culture i think i
learned from richard branson
so before i was at thredup i spent seven
years working at the virgin group
and started a bunch of businesses there
was involved in starting a bunch of
businesses there
and i brought a lot of those learnings
to to thread up and culture is i always
think about it it's like the three c's
culture is
it's complicated and it can be
controversial
i focus on the complicated part meaning
it's hard to get your head around or put
your finger on any one thing at any one
time
when you're trying to be relevant from a
cultural standpoint and
meet people where they are and talk
about topics and get involved in
conversations
that people care about so the way we
think about it on the team here is
there's small culture and there's big
culture and
small culture is when somebody on the
thredup team reads in the burberry
annual report that they're burning
clothing that they can't sell
and we we take that little that little
moment that little bit of information
and we turn it into an open letter on
instagram that goes viral
that's small culture that's little
things that are happening
here and there that are under the radar
or are subtle
or don't appear to even be cultural
what's what's sort of appears to be less
cultural than burning
luxury products in some obscure field
somewhere but
when you you know put a light on it and
put it in the context of your business
and your values and what your customers
care about
it gets it gets some legs and then
there's big culture so
we recently did a collaboration with
eric domin who's the designer on gossip
girl you know so
believe me i'm old enough where i was a
fan of gossip girl before it was a
remake i was
i was there with the originals i'm sort
of old og gossip girl
you want a fun fact chuck bass is the
only person in my life that i've ever
asked for a selfie
yeah i was so deep gossip girl and it's
when it when i saw chuck
of madison's queer garden and lost my
mind like i was a fan of liam at one
direction jerry that nft would would
probably sell for a lot of money yeah i
actually have it on my phone go ahead
and look for it i need to cover that
okay
so those are examples of big culture
sort of bigger cultural waves that are
going on and then there's sort of the
biggest culture of all which is the
increasing emphasis and focus that
people have on sustainability
it was awful it was 111 degrees outside
my house
here in california you know there was a
sinkhole the size of a warehouse in
germany
across the world just a few weeks ago
people are experiencing
weather and life in ways where
everyone's saying hey that like headless
horseman
of climate change that seemed to be like
way off in the distance and obscure the
headless horseman's now standing in
everybody's living room
so there's mega mega cultural waves like
that and
so at thredup we try to like think of
our business and our customer
and what our customers care about and
then from that like range of small
culture to big culture find ways to play
that we can
educate our customers to help them live
smarter better more
more economical lives and then like a
thread up we got to do something about
it we have to deliver the goods and so
we process
hundreds of millions of items help you
shop used help you save money help you
look amazing
are a lot of people garage saleing and
thrifting and free marketing and then
flipping to you and it's like a business
for them
uh yes uh but most people
like nine 99.99 are
busy with their kids with their families
with their jobs with their lives
and their clients it's a closet yeah
what's up and they're like
please send me a bag i'm excited to be
part of the 0.001
obviously obviously we're still
snatching i mean like
no no no no i you know correct me if i'm
wrong like i can go garage sailing
find some epic you know female and kids
clothes
send it off to you and make an arm you
can
okay and i want to yeah please do
just send us only women i know i saw i
saw i saw
i just uh while you were talking i went
on the site and i found an
epic teenage mutant ninja turtles female
t-shirt i just tweeted it out
because i had so many flippers on me i
think it's super underpriced
i can go for like 75 bucks in a
different environment that's like 12
bucks on the site sub
i'm loving it listen thank you so much
talk to you soon pleasure see you gary
so gary that our team wants you to take
a break and try to find that photo real
quick for them if you don't mind
i don't mind okay next up we welcome our
friend
mark schiller he's the ceo of hane
celestial
the organic and natural products company
with dozens of leading brands sold in 75
different countries
brands like celestial seasonings
sensible portions
tara albert and earth's best
mark lives by the 3h rule always be
hungry
humble and happy and the rest will take
care of itself
welcome mark thank you hey gary
hey brother how are you virtual fist
pump yeah i like seeing you my man you
well
yeah great all is good knowing that
that's the corporate name why don't you
tell
some people first so they get some
context on you on what brands
sit under uh hane and then uh and then
we'll get into this
sure so we have about 35 brands um
celestial seasonings tea is one of our
biggest sensible portion veggie straws
tara chips alba sunscreens and uh
shampoos
um maranatha almond butter imagine
soup uh earth's best organic baby foods
a ton of brands across the
categories and the common thread for all
of us they're healthy
and they do good things for your body
and your soul
so when i let just go literal with you
because i've been bouncing around
everywhere else when i when i say
how do you stay close to culture being a
ceo of such a large company
having you know family having life you
know
is it as much of a challenge as i think
it is to st
to really know what's cool and relevant
with consumers or
do you have some hacks some different
ways thoughts on that
yeah so um as you know it's it's busy at
being a ceo but i'm
i'm a naturally curious person so
um you know when i'm watching a movie
i'm paying attention to the people in
the background not the guy that's
speaking in the foreground
i go to go to the city and i sit on a
park bench and i just watch people walk
by for an hour and try and guess what
their occupation is i mean that's just
the way i'm wired
interesting um and then i've got five
kids who are all in their 20s
who keep me very abreast of kind of
what's going on with that age group and
then
and then look social media i watch i
watch gary vaynerchuk on tick tock
and to see what you're saying and doing
and a lot and you know
dozens and dozens of other people so um
it's just kind of part of my dna
i'm the only you know late 50 year old
sitting at gov ball in new york city
listening to
you know rappers i i i it's amazing how
many times i
i say i'm by far the oldest person here
are not and the answer is that's okay
because i'm staying learning i'm fine
uh you just keep your fair on the pulse
of it how do you then
inspire your marketers
who are really trying to win that game
with consumer
you know is that because you're that way
do you feel that trickles into the dna
do you feel like your cmos and brand
managers feel a little pressure like i
can't have mark
be cooler and know what's going on than
me or do you create structured things as
people start building their orgs
and they want their org to represent
that strength if they're lucky enough to
have it
is that something how do you think about
that how do you how do you scale it i
guess at the end of the day yeah
well so look first i'm always pushing
people to to
be further ahead and be more edgy
because i somebody said it earlier today
um brands are resilient you can make
mistakes
and and you know as long as you don't
make too many of them the consumer will
come back
the other thing we do at hayne which i
think works really well
is we have a shark tank mentality so our
brand people get
zero budget you have to come and make a
case for why we should invest in your
idea
oh wow them to come up with something
compelling
that's worth investing it doesn't mean
you always have to have a big study that
shows me what the roi
is but if it if it feels like it's going
to get noticed it's going to build the
brand it's going to make a difference
we'll bet on it and
sometimes we're wrong sometimes we're
right i'd say we're right more often
than we're wrong
but it creates a culture of be curious
push the envelope
be passionate about what it is that you
believe in and go sell it i
had one of um our african-american
employees came to me recently we have a
very small
personal care brand called queen helene
which caters to the african-american
market
and she came and made a business case on
how she could turn this into a health
and wellness brand
and really capture that audience in a
much different way than we had
and in about six seconds i was like do
it go tell me what you need
you know you're you are trying to create
value for us as a company
by pushing toward uh an underserved
group by us
love it go for it bring you back your
plan and let's go make it happen
part of your career and which mentor
or individual me the natural thing that
you are as a human being much like me
the same way i shot watching people
figure it out
in real life because at 17 you realize
that was a skill
a business skill that wasn't like how
your brain tends to work at 17 what
at what place were you given courage of
like wait a minute
this is a superpower strength something
that might propel my career
because i think a lot of people i want
to take advantage of that question
because i think a lot of people may in
certain parts
and i'd like to know you know where that
happened for you in what company what
environment
yeah it's it's a great question i think
um because i've just
always been naturally curious and um
i get bored easily i'm i just
find things to move around so for
example i've moved 23 times in my life
one more time 23 you have moved
24 days three times in your life yes
i've lived in 10 different states in the
united states and abroad
and so i'm just constantly
trying experimenting doing new things um
i'm a big
music guy when i go travel abroad the
first thing i do is i find out where the
music scene is and even in a language i
totally don't understand
i want to see who's there what they're
doing it's just it's what makes me happy
um and and when i pick a career to your
point
um i've switched industries multiple
times and i started in food
but then i ran the world's largest
manufacturer of coin operated pool
tables
and then i went from that to running the
world's largest franchisor of daycare
centers
and then i went back to food and so i
just i bounce around
based on my values based on what's
interesting to me at the time
um i think my parents instilled that in
me when i was young explore
try new things um you're young you can
fail now
you know go out and make your mark and
figure out what makes you happy and
that's just kind of stuck with me and i
try and instill it in my kids
how do you teach that to executives that
are too rigid
want to be promoted to the highest
levels
because because i'm listening to you and
this just popped up
have you found it you know you had the
luxury of your parents creating that
culture
you know uh do you have you been able to
get executives who are too rigid too
type a
to school have you been able to inspire
and create environments where people
have changed moved a little bit down the
line like
do you feel that's a dna trait and you
just are like what's your take on that
i think for some people it's it's deeply
embedded in their dna they are who they
are
um but i go back to you know my 3 8 rule
i tell people be happy
if this doesn't make you happy find
something else that does and if you're
if you're on an assignment that doesn't
stimulate you and you want to do
something else let's have a conversation
about it
and the ones that that have the
potential to be much more exploratory
and
uh are willing to push the envelope i'm
always there to support them but not
everybody
is like that to your point and so i try
to find people when we're hiring
that are like that that are really going
to push the paradigm that we're in
because otherwise brands get stale and
companies get stale and you get left
behind
i think that's right what um what back
to social when we got two minutes
you watching me on t talk which i
appreciate have you um
do you have a favorite platform and how
much uh
of the kids i'm sure with five of them
in that range some are really into it
others aren't everyone's got different
personalities
you know i feel social media represents
an opportunity to discover what's
actually happening and
which which platforms do you gravitate
to more and
and then finally mix in there as well
how much
do your kids send you stuff or vice
versa or who in the who of the kids is
really driving that
yeah so um i spend most of my time on on
youtube and tick tock
um and what i love about um both of
those platforms is there are so many
subcultures on there
uh you know if you want if you're
interested in investing they've got 100
people that will tell you about that if
you're interested in bodybuilding
they'll tell you about that if you're
interested in food or great restaurants
to go to or places to travel you can
really find what
interests you and immerse yourself
deeply on those
um you know my kids are an interesting
group because you know
it's fascinating when you have five
children from the same two parents how
different they all end up being
um but i have my oldest son has uh has
down syndrome so there's
my daughter is very passionate about
disability the disability community
and is constantly sending me things on
what's happening
uh we're going to this event do you want
to come um
i have a son who programs missiles for
the government's patriot missile defense
program
who is very passionate about computers
and technology
and defense uh i have a chemical
engineer son who is
always tinkering with things and um
talking about you know how you can put
different things together to create
something new or how
how uh some of the things that you see
on social media like dropping the
you know the the tab and creates an
explosion
um and then my youngest one just
graduated he's moving out to denver he's
the outdoors guy
so he's passionate about hiking and
hiking and all and fitness and all those
kinds of things so
they're all really different but they
all feed into me
personally in different ways and keep me
abreast of kind of what's going on out
there and then i bring them music and
some of the things i'm passionate about
thank you for bringing your passion
today mark stay well talk to you soon my
pleasure
hey gary we've got one last discussion
with the power duo
of avery akanini and kirsten corrio
of the united states tennis association
and i think they're i think they're
going to be saying goodbye to you
gary bye everybody we have avery here
who uh leads uh vayner nft uh
and uh i'm excited for all of you get to
know and one of my favorite executives i
met her
very early in my career and uh and i'm
excited to be reconnected so i'm gonna
be listening carefully it's great to see
both of you ladies all three of you
power ladies
i will be jumping off by everybody thank
you
thank you gary i just want to introduce
um kirsten
a bit more kirsten is the managing
director of the united states tennis
association
where she's responsible for three of the
most
significant lines of business associated
with the usta
and the u.s open she does all things
ticket and hospitality sales and
operations
international broadcast partnerships and
is in charge of all of the digital
platforms so i'll leave it up to
the two of you can't wait to learn more
awesome thanks andre welcome kirsten uh
thank you so much for joining us and
being with us today
i'm a huge fan of tennis and usta as you
know so super honored to have you on the
show
it's my pleasure to be here good to see
you avery awesome
so you've had an amazing career um with
incredible roles that all kinds of sort
of culturally defining associations and
institutions
and you know some of the other folks on
here who have been sort of representing
brands they're leaning in always like
what's happening in culture but in a lot
of ways
sports associations really drive that
culture so
you know in your from your perspective
um how does a brand or association stay
close to culture or even shape culture
in some of your cases yeah you know it's
interesting
it was great for me to listen to some of
those speakers right before me
and i've been so lucky to work for these
incredible brands you know
first the nba where i learned from
arguably the greatest marketer in the
world david stern
uh what an honor and a privilege there
um but you know the nba
do you say to your point it is culture
you've got you know over 400 players
about a quarter of them come from
international countries representing 40
40 different unique countries and
they're in that sweet spot 18 to 34.
these guys our culture they represent
culture
and you know for the us open and and
i'll speak for the other grand slams
here as well
uh what i love so much about the culture
that they represent
is really this this forever gender
neutral
the most gender neutral sport men watch
women women watch men
the us open was the first event to offer
equal pay for women 50 years ago and
that's very culturally relevant still
today
crazy that it's still relevant today but
but um it's it's really cool to see the
impact on culture these
these two sports and all the all other
sports that you know i feel like i'm a
fan of every sport
have had on both culture and community
and and brand and so of course you know
rants want to be close to that they need
to be close to sports they need to be
close to culture they need to be close
to kids
kids in that spot of of 12 to 24
12 to 18 um they're following these
sports they're emulating everything you
see in these sports
and so they need to be close to be
relevant into growth they also need to
be close to purchasing power a little
bit older
in order to uh to thrive as a business
but
you know sports reflects culture and
culture reflects sports and it's just a
it's so much fun to be
doing this for a living yeah and i think
it's really interesting because
um yes there's the culture of of sports
fans but oftentimes
um what's happening in some of these
major associations and leagues is
ultimately shapes what's happening in
the broader conversation you just
brought it up around equal pay
i think it has happened recently around
mental health um and some of the sports
that you're sort of helping to represent
um do sort of shape that conversation
and not just national media but also in
global media
which is awesome um you're really at the
forefront and leading it
so us open is coming up this year talk
about something that shapes culture i
know there's probably a lot of new
yorkers on this stream
and everyone looks forward to their
honeydews at uh at the us um so what can
we look forward to this year what are
you all cooking up
yeah me too we are thrilled to be
bringing it back with fans 100
capacity let's go uh our marketing
campaign really reflects that the
marketing campaign that's voiced by
lin-manuel miranda
is the greatest return and you know
you've got the return of the serve and
tennis you've also got the return of new
york the return of fans to live events
we could not be more thrilled and a
honeydew is just the icing on the cake
i hope to see lots and lots of you there
um but but
you know there's a lot cooking that's
going to be unique and different not
just because we're actually going to
have the event with fans and it's going
to feel i hope very close to
to normal or the new normal um but
a few things that are new few things
cooking electronic line calling on all
courts this year
no lines people uh so that will be new
for this year if you follow tennis you
may already know that but if not
um you know it will be a change for this
year
um one thing that may be relevant for
this audience we are going to be
releasing our first ever nft collection
for the 2021 us open
that we're very excited about and we
couldn't do it without the help of
people like avery and her team
uh you know so it's a little teased
there we're going to be looking
to around the mid-august time frame but
uh i can't share much more detail about
it right now
awesome well thanks for for sharing that
wasn't sure if we were going to share
that news now or later but a lot more
um coming on that front and it's been
amazing to see some of the developments
in the nft space over the past
you know six months to a year um i know
many of the folks in the stream also
probably um are familiar with gary's
project which is v
friends um you know really doing
something that's
defining within culture by creating some
an intellectual property that existed
first as nfts
i think with um you know association
like uh usta
um you all are actually doing something
very innovative um
within this space within sports um but
could also be sort of a defining program
for years to come
uh which we hope it will be um
you know i think that people are are
using entities for a number of different
purposes there's like the collectible
angle there's
event access there's provenance and art
um ownership
um community building and i'm curious
from your perspective as
such a shaper of culture um what do you
think is actually driving this adoption
um towards nfts outside of just like the
pr headlines and the buzz that people
are
are talking about just in the past
couple months you know i've been
thinking about this avery
and i get asked this question a lot
especially internally from people that
aren't as close to it
as i am now we've been drinking from
this fire hose for
you know six months in trying to ingest
as much information and learn as much as
we can
and to try to be as thoughtful as we
could from a brand approach perspective
and representing our legacy in the right
way
and and approaching our fans in the
right way and trying to engage new fans
in the right way uh but the truth is
i don't know i don't know what's driving
it and i still don't know no matter how
much i'm drinking from the fire hose i
know a little bit more than most people
in my my organization but that's it
which is why we really you know we knew
early on we needed to engage some people
that knew more than we did
uh your team has been super helpful in
that regard and
and you know i i think there's there's a
lot to
to learn still there's a lot more for us
to learn we hope this year is really a
test and learn
opportunity for us to really understand
what's resonating with people and what's
sticking
and and what do people want more of what
do they really want out of this space
from from a live sports property um
that you know has iconic moments in its
past will have iconic moments in its
future
and and you know what's the way that we
tap audience and grow audience in that
way together as a
an ecosystem of sports for tennis
broadly but specifically of course for
for the us open so
i don't really know but uh there's
certainly a lot that a lot of people
find
super interesting and compelling and and
future changing about it and so
we know we need to be a part of that and
we need to learn as much as we can
yeah absolutely i think it's future
changing but also in the case of the us
open like even uh you know i just i
moved back from singapore recently as
you know and
we actually even moved to singapore some
like us open cups and like some
memorabilia so in some ways it's very
future forward but in some ways it's
just a sort of consumer behavior that's
coming to the digital sphere as well
um so i think it's it's interesting
because in a lot of ways it's uh just a
continuation of something that people
have been doing forever
like saving us open memorabilia saving
their tickets
you know dying to do a meet and greet
with their favorite players um just a
new way to sort of
bring that up um awesome so
uh kristen any sort of closing words you
have for the audience on on things that
they can do to stay close to culture or
what they should be uh
watching out for in the tennis tennis
world you know i'd say close to culture
the only thing that helps keep me
relevant besides you know consuming as
much media as i can
from people that i think are smarter
than me is is i always ask
every everyone younger than me
particularly those 12 to 24
how do you communicate with your friends
what do you guys think is cool
what are you what are you watching now
what are you looking at where are you
consuming it
and it's it's often surprising i mean
the latest thing that
some of the kids some of my daughters
friends are into right now are baby
puffs
and if you don't know what that is like
melt in your mouth little baby puffs
maybe
you know mark from hayne knows what
these are but they're meant for
infants and as a first food and this
became something that's you know
according to them
everyone's into right now so i don't
know it's if that's culture defining but
you know it's just an example of ways
that these kids are consuming media
differently they're doing everything
differently
and they're going to set the future for
fan behavior and fan consumption
and so uh for me that's very helpful and
just you know trying to stay close to
what's coming
um and for the tennis world look there
there's a lot to watch in the upcoming
us open series that are starting shortly
but the us open itself
starts on august 30th as many people may
know novak djokovic is going for
an historic grand slam if he if he were
to win this year as us open he'd be the
first man to do it
in over 50 years um so we're
we're watching everyone else should be
watching it's gonna be really exciting
this run and hopefully
uh many of you are with us in queens
with the honeydews
all right amazing i just got goosebumps
just hearing about that but uh yeah
andrea
i know you're you're set to close us off
and and thanks kirsten for joining us
my pleasure thanks so much to you both
that's great news the u.s opened
august 30th we'll be there and i'm
hoping all of you will join us on our
next episode
august 19th from 12 noon to 1 p.m that's
eastern time please join us
and if you'd like check out some of our
past episodes on
mftn marketing for the now
mftn.vaynerx.com
keep the dialogue going hashtag
marketing for the now and we'll see you
soon thanks for
joining us